you got this hit TV show you're writing
a book you also co-host a podcast and
the podcast like your book is called
unqualified yes and it's become it's
like a big deal it's a hit it's a hit
podcast I started it as a hobby like
because I I wanted to talk about myself
and because celebrities rarely get the
chance yeah and actually I wanted to
talk to strangers and feel like we
haven't but not in a creepy way right
exactly
no in a slightly creepy way yeah that's
you know I'm a little creeped you know
I'm a creep yeah you're no no you're not
I wouldn't say it all you're a creep I'm
a creep you but you and I get along well
because of that but now you're teaching
this is cool you're teaching a course at
USC called creating the hit podcast so
you're now giving people advice college
students you are a college instructor at
USC which is a big deal school well back
it up I am a professor are you really
[Applause]
call me dr. Farris yeah that's what the
car codes do it over again dr. Ferris Oh
dr. Ferris how are you I'm well thank
you
you are from an academic family right
yeah so what me so who's in academia my
brother is a fourth generation
sociologist so anyway my dad my
grandfather my great-grandfather
everyone's and uncles and aunts and
cousins are they cool with the fact that
you're now teaching at a school at a
college no they're like uh dr. Ferris
you have it all now yeah yeah so they
give you a hard time about the whole
thing
well they definitely think I'm
unqualified
[Laughter]
you